hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the women's section of
the FED Grand Swiss we have a game from
the penultimate round Vali is facing tan
jongi former women's world champion um
she reigned in 2017 and she's currently
reigning as the women's rapid world
champion uh so wonderful game and uh
interestingly both of them qualified for
the for the candidates tournament but uh
it's the the game most of you requested
even though all of um the the games were
really wonderful uh so let's check it
out why shy has the white pieces and she
opens with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C5
Knight F3 Pawn to D6 and D4 so
challenging the Sicilian by opening up
the position we have captures captures
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and uh sorry
Knight to C3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to
G5 this is the uh R Rouser variation of
the classical Sicilian we have Bishop to
D7 and now uh it's a pretty standard
position um more than a couple of
thousand games in the database Queen to
D2 is the most common move here it's
been played pretty much by everyone Ari
andar for example played it against
Magnus Carlson uh in 2020 in Norway
chess he lost that game but uh you know
everyone plays it but here we have a
very very rare line only been played a
handful of times captures on C6 Bishop
captures Bishop captures on F6 G
captures and Bishop to B5 only a few
games in the database where black
usually replies by capturing the bishop
or if you in the bishop to G7 it's not
really even a faneto as the pawn
structure has been ruined but instead we
have Rook to G8 and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so uh tanong says all right thank you
for the semiopen G file and if you
capture on C6 I will also claim the
semiopen B file so okay we have Castles
by by sh not afraid of the of the Rook
on G8 we have Queen to D7 and now B
Bishop captures and C6 capturing with
the B Pawn as it it helps um tanji
improve her Center and now Pawn to F4 so
it's a very very strange position where
obviously if if there was anything here
well it would be played more but uh Vali
prepared the prepared prepared it and
tungi will have to show that she's able
to find her way through all the
intricacies of the position so Rook to
B8 claiming the semiopen B file as well
for her rook and now Queen to F3
offering the B2 Pawn uh now you can
capture it but it's not really a great
capture uh to to explain why if you
capture it then Rook eight to B1 now if
you trade then white will be controlling
the B file and Rook to B8 will always be
a problem and if you play Rook to B6 to
kind of ask white are you may be
interested in capturing so I can even
fix my Pawn structure then you go A4
preparing A5 and if E5 uh attacking in
the center now you play A5 and now black
will have to move the Rook captures
captures and after let's say Bishop D E7
you you cannot block with Bishop to d8
uh A6 and this is now very very annoying
for black and now the Rook can come to
B7 the rook and come to B8 you will
probably have to trade Queens here let's
say captures captures Knight to E2
defend here and now after e captures you
will go Rook to B8 with check and after
Bishop to d8 you will go Knight to D4
and okay now this Pawn is weak this Pawn
is weak the Knight can come to F5 you
have doubled pawns here uh White um
should have a a much nicer game so while
you can capture on B2 you don't really
gain anything by it so Queen to G4
offering a queen trade and just Pawn to
B3 uh improving the position here saying
okay if you want to trade you can trade
by capturing the queen here and I will
uh recapture with the Rook but of course
tan doesn't she goes Rook to
B4 uh Rook a to D1 and now just Pawn to
A6 we have Queen to F2 now the queen uh
trade is no longer on the table and
while you are pressuring the A7 point
you also have to defend Checkmate on G2
so you can't move for the moment we have
Pawn to F5 and pawn to A3 chasing away
The Rook we have Rook back to B7 and now
Rook to D3 now uh Rook to G3 is a pretty
big threat so you have to take care of
that and we have Bishop to E7 now uh
Bishop to E7 how does Bishop to E7 uh
help you with Rook to G3 well if you go
Rook to G3 right away then Bishop to H4
that is the idea uh now
nothing is really happening here if you
capture the queen then Bishop captures
and F2 comes with check and you don't
have to worry about Rook captures and G8
coming with check once you capture here
captures and of course black will be uh
up the exchange and winning the game so
instead after Bishop D7 we have King to
H1 and now Bishop to H4 still attacking
the queen uh Queen to D2 now you could
trade Queens here it is very much
possible let's say H3 you trade here
Bishop captures H captures the bishop
still hanging you have to move the
bishop and now after let's say G
captures an F5 you will capture another
Pawn black pushes D5 and okay white is
up a pawn but has a double F Pawn and
black has a a bishop versus a knight so
white should probably be a little bit
better but nothing spectacular so
instead of I plays Queen to D2 keeps the
Queens in the game and also puts
pressure on that D6 pawn and now Pawn to
D5 we have Pawn to H3 attacking the
queen queen to G6 we have e captures on
F5 Queen captur on F5 and now Knight to
E2 uh defending on on F4 but also just
getting ready to bring that Knight over
to uh D4 to attack the queen to put
pressure on C6 and so on so Pawn to E5
stopping that and now Rook to E3
aligning The Rook nicely with the black
king and now the only way to defend this
is to play Pawn to E4 but it was not
played in the game here tanong played
Rook to E7 and now uh Vali uh take takes
over the game completely she plays Queen
to B4 and now the threat is a fairly
simple one Rook Queen to B8 check will
win the Rook on G8 so you have to defend
this somehow either by moving the king
or by defending the Rook tanong defends
the rook and now also threatens
Checkmate but Pawn to G4 defends against
Checkmate and now you still have to
worry about all of these checks checks
will pick up the pawn you might lose
this Pawn at some point uh this will
create a past a pawn if you don't have
anything on the king side this will be
very very bad for Tan jungi so she
continues the attack Pawn to H5 we have
F captures on E5 H captures on G4 and
only now Queen to B8 with check we have
King to D7 Queen captures an A7 with
check King to C8 and now Queen to A8
with check we have King to C7 and now
again Queen to A7 with check King to C8
and queen to A6 with check she repeated
once but now uh she will continue of
course King to C7 and now Knight to4
attacking the queen and where can the
queen go to there are a couple of
squares but none of them really work it
doesn't matter if you go Queen to G5
Queen to G7 you could go Queen to H6 you
could go Queen captures and C2 none of
these uh work and the black just gets
destroyed whatever she does uh for
example if Queen to G5 do you see how
white wins on the spot it's a fairly uh
straightforward idea but uh you know may
maybe you don't see it uh you know while
I give you a couple of
seconds
uh the move of course is Knight captures
on D5 with check and now there's nothing
uh that you can do here uh it's check
and also the Rook is attacked um if you
go some like King to be then Rook E4 of
course you're not going to give up The
Rook Rook E4 followed by Rook here and
if you take doesn't really help you that
much then comes Rook to C3 with check
and after the king moves you will play
Rook to C5 and you just get uh um a
checkm for example Rook to B7 will will
be met with Queen to D6 check King d8
Rook to A5 check Rook to A7 Queen to C6
check King goes to B8 and now of course
Rook B5 only move Rook to B7 and this
will be Checkmate so uh Queen to G5
doesn't work this is met the same this
is met the same this is met the same
this is met the same what can you play
here Queen to H7 was played but again it
doesn't work uh so here Vali repeated
once Queen to A7 with check King to C8
Queen to A8 with check King to C7 sorry
uh King to D7 and now Queen to B7 with
check King to d8 and now Queen to B8
with check King to D7 Queen to B7 with
check King d8 and now Queen captures on
C6 even though she could have gone for
that Knight captur on D5 idea uh she
decided to go for this I don't know
probably already the penultimate round
after a grueling tournament you know a
spot in the candidates tournament is
hanging in the balance you don't want to
over over
um calculate and then maybe maybe miss
something this is pretty straightforward
and now you know that you will win this
Rook to C7 was played now Queen captures
on D5 with check King to E8 and now
Queen to A8 with check uh Bishop to d8
of course blocking and now Rook to D1
going after the bishop this will be
Checkmate so Queen to H4 defending the
bishop here luckily uh the H3 Pawn is
defended by the Knight so we don't have
to worry but now B finishes it off with
a very nice Rook e D3 and he was in this
position on move 43 that tongi resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the d8 bishop is attacked
three times and that's all there is if
you move the king to E7 uh it's possible
okay now the bishop is defended by the
by The Rook as well but now it's not
defended by the queen so that doesn't
really help you all that much uh so yeah
here she resigns there's no move you can
play or getting checkmated whatever you
play and uh Vali not only wins the
tournament she wins wins the Women's Fed
Grand swiss but she also qualifies for
the FED candidate candidates tournament
and interestingly uh she qualifies for
the candidates tournament as a
international Master she's still not a
grand master even though she has her
three norns but she's still not 20 2500
rated so once she reaches
2500 uh she will uh get her Grandmaster
title uh although uh I I think it's um
if you guys remember when Bobby fiser
qualified for the FED granded fed cand
tournament he was not a grandmas and he
was granted the title because it would
be weird for not a grandmas to to play
in the candidates tournament and while
it is I believe the same for men's
candidates now I I I think you don't get
the title right away if you qualify for
for the women's candidates tournament I
could be wrong but I I I don't think you
do uh but yeah she does have her norms
and once she reaches she got like over
30 rating points in this tournament so
she will break 2500 uh fairly quickly
and she and these are the opponents that
she faced so she played an Immaculate
tournament not a single loss she started
with a win against Olivia kobasa then a
draw against Elena rubar for those of
you who are following women's just know
how strong uh these um uh women are I
mean they're playing absolutely
incredible chess they're just crushing
everyone so Vali defeating them or or
you know even even playing against them
is is really awesome then uh against
Maria muuk and Anna muuk she got a draw
in the win Alexander gachin draw bisara
also a win um Sophie Miler of France it
was a really crazy game everything was
hanging there that that was a draw then
she defeated antoneta stefanova then tan
jongi uh and um well pretty pretty
incredible tournament in the tournament
she faced um uh three participants of
the of the women's candidates tournament
that will be playing in 2024 and she got
two draws and win against them so if she
will play like this or or maybe even a
little bit better as the candidates
tournament is next year she could even
be the the favorite to play in the
women's feed candidates tournament so
for now uh if you don't know who is
currently qualified for the women's feed
day candidates tournament we have uh
think gai she qualified through the uh
last um world CH Championship cycle as
she was the runner up then the top two
finishers of the women's Grand Prix uh
LNO and Alexandra gachina then the top
three finishers of the women's Chess
World Cup nuro salimova and Anna muuk
and then you have the top two finishers
of this tournament the F women's Grands
withs Vali and tan jongi tan jongi
actually won third place um ana muuk won
second place but as she qualified before
uh the the spot goes to tanong uh one
more uh one more player will be decided
whoever will be the highest rated player
on the January list of 2024 same same as
in the open section uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done byali choosing this um uh
line that sort of doesn't offer that
much but you have to play very very
precise I mean this Knight captures on
C6 and Bishop captures on F6 uh but you
have to play very precise and she just
you know uh she just uh basically
imposed her will on the former women's
world champion uh but yeah something uh
something
let's say Bobby fiser used to do in the
in the ru Lopez where he would um you
know capture with with u Bishop captures
and C6 he would just take the Knight
even though he was considered that it's
nothing he would still play it and he
would just Crush people so yeah there we
have it very nicely done by Vali big
congratulations on qualifying for the
candidates tournament and uh very soon I
believe getting her Grandmaster uh title
I would like to thank Sam's giant toris
far marwin Sparrow Gard hlan perfora
love Marie and India for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and I
do have a nice photo of vidit and Vali
after the tournament here if you guys
want to uh see if you haven't seen it
let me just see if I can find it to end
the video with that uh since it's really
is a nice one uh yeah here it is okay
let's let's just check that out sorry
it's it's a bit large have to make it
smaller yeah we have a very nice photo
so they both uh they both won the
tournament and they both qualified for
the feay candidates tournament 2024 uh
see you
soon